ride through the city like BR sh I'm on
a mission to get it all
through the city
[Music]
like now
Brandon six
boy
sh what is popping fam on the dot it is
9 a.m. we are live we do it live we do
it live what's popping kids uh November
6 that's right it we're in November we
are in November
and things are going
stupendously hopefully you guys had a
great weekend I was
in Niagara Falls New York uh about 20
minutes outside
Buffalo um spent uh the entire weekend
there before that I was in Orlando went
to the
Olympia um Miss SEMA I miss SEMA I can't
tell you how much that really IRS me I
miss SEMA and uh I just watched on
Instagram everybody else having so much
fun doing stuff I love with car builds
and superchargers and blowers and valves
and wheels and tires and all sorts of
stuff I want to see but no I was at the
Olympia staring at dudes so quite the
difference fam uh that's all right
that's all right people sent me pictures
it's just the same uh Niagara Falls
never been I'm 40 never been to Niagara
Falls uh so I feel like it was time to
grow up grow a mustache and go check out
nagra Falls and uh get there and uh you
know it's a lot of water falling and
then you you you get there and you just
look you go oh cool and then you kind of
just walk back and that's all you do now
here's the thing that I going to tell
you on the on the United States side
um it's it's uh it's not the good side
which is very rare most people are
trying to break in and come to the
United States and uh this is not the
case on the Canadian side there it's a
much better View and uh it's a nicer
area it's a much nicer area um the area
that we're in is uh a little rough
around those parts a little rough some
bullet holes and stop signs okay not
gonna lie to you but uh it was a great
great time great show shout out to
senica casino out there shout out to oh
God I kept calling her scooter um but
her name's not scoot she was she was so
cool man the manager of the senica
casino she was the best um but yeah
Niger Falls Niger Falls of course
Buffalo invented uh the chicken wing so
they say I don't know if I uh if I
believe that but apparently they
invented the the chicken wing and that
is where the first chicken wing was
invented that's at Anchorage um and
they're they're solid they are they're I
give them a nine out of 10 um they're
good it's all about the crisp man are
they better than JT's Wings in Phoenix
are they it's going to hurt some
people's feelings
you know what I'm going to do this
different
different right easy bailout different
just different they're different yeah
they're different um those and then
duffs are good too but apparently all
the the locals was telling me we messed
up we should have went to some bar that
has the best ones apparently those are
the tourist spots so all right my bad I
didn't
know my bat did not know man but uh yeah
shout out to nagaral shout out to
Buffalo much better time in Buffalo now
the when I was cut by the team not going
to lie to you guys I had a grand old
time uh I was able to watch the one
Championship card so my boy uh Hagerty
uh just beat the
breakes beat the breakes off Andra um he
looked fantastic called it uh Ruto doing
what he does best choking dudes uh out
but he won uh unanimous decision but one
Championship that was a great card man
such a good card so many finishes and
even the decision were dope and then you
had uh the fight
night now the casino we're at senica
casino out there Niagara Falls uh my
brother and uh my feature Brett Forte
who's Canadian he uh they're betters
they bet on everything over under how
many chicken wings we're going to eat
over under how many people we're going
to see riding bikes around Agro Falls
they they bet on everything and so we
got done with the show around 10 the
good thing about the East Coast is the
UFC doesn't start till 10:00 so we're
able to watch most of it my CU Buff's
game start at 10:00 even though they
lost again so that's cool but um we were
able to watch the co-main event the
co-main event Dolby and bonfim was
ridiculous so ridiculous Dolby looked F
such a monster um and then the main
event you had alme and Derrick Lewis I
was all up on almeida's um long long uh
wiener Brazilian wiener I was very I was
riding that thing hard dude and you guys
know you know it and uh I was all in on
this guy I was all on this guy in that
beautiful gorgeous body that he owns um
and then he fought Derrick Lewis and it
was five rounds of a straight up
Brazilian jiu-jitsu match he inflicted
no damage uh his this where people get
confused they're like man he can
wrestle yes against Rosen stro against
Derrick Lewis he can
wrestle he I
I'm not hating on the guy in any fasted
he's so skillful should probably be a
light heavyweight um he's gonna struggle
to To Be A Champion um because his his
his wrestling is not at the level of say
you know a Curtis blades a Jon Jones a
DC when you get to those upper echon
guys where he's going to be able to
inflict his you know will and get guys
down at all cost he's going be forced to
stand with a guy like Curtis blades he's
going to be forced to stand with a guy
like as and all um outside that he's
going to do pretty well but um the
chance of him being champion at
heavyweight is not great after watching
that Derrick Lewis fight uh there was no
damage done with the ground and pound he
didn't have that killer mentality
looking for Relentless submissions he
spent I don't know the fight was 25
minutes long inside that octagon he
probably spent 20 minutes in Mount derck
Lewis didn't have a freaking bruise on
his face so for Al can get dicey here
because he was kind of the the poster
boy and everyone's high and mighty on
him he was getting these first round
finishes and choking people out and then
you see the nasty side of the UFC brass
when things like this happen in Main
Event now he's GNA learn oh I need to
switch up my my fighting style because
um and I would say he's going to be
disciplined because he was supposed to
fight Chris blades in in the first part
and the only reason he's fighting
uh Derrick Lewis is
because um Curtis blades got hurt so if
he would have went out there and
starched Derrick Lewis and choked him
out in the first round or second round
and you know did his thing I think he
would have been able to bypass a lot of
tough contenders and get a title shot
probably either title shot or they gave
him s Gan s gan's a great fight for him
super great fight for him so uh that's
not going to be the case now now the UFC
is going oh no no no no no no no you're
getting cursed blades next you're going
to be forced to strike you're going to
be forced to go for a finish and that's
just he's see he's going to see the
remember it is it is a sport but it's
it's show business so now he's going to
see the show business side side of
fighting and it's it's going to hurt his
feelings because the UFC is going to
discipline him for that performance even
though he probably had four 10 eight
rounds sure man you dominated in every
aspect of that uh fight but uh it wasn't
entertaining any fast it you going to
learn now you going learn now so the way
they make him learn is by fighting a
Curtis blades um volov could be a tough
one for him um but yet he's not gonna
get catapulted to a title shot after
that he had the potential to and now
they're going to make his Road a little
tougher little tougher I could see him
uh cutting to light heavyweight
eventually because be very tough for him
to beat guys like Curtis blades or um or
Aspen and also your boy Pat hips isn't
too bad either so those could be some
some tough tests for him so we'll see
we'll see but don't get it twisted don't
get he's he's getting you know guys down
he's wrestling his chain wrestling you
know he he he he does well with it with
guys who have absolutely no experience
wrestling when he starts getting to
those higher level guys it's it's going
to be a tough night in the office for
him I think very tough very very tough
so he's had an easy Road and now he's
going to he's going to learn what the
UFC is he's the only one what the UFC is
I think his Future's at 205 though not
going to lie to
you but at least at least you got the
win at least he got the win Hagerty
London's finest doing the damn thing
double champ champ now so um we'll see
man it's all everything's headed towards
UFC 295 this Saturday now for the
casuals you're going to be a little
disappointed that uh Jon Jones and Steve
is not on there um a little disappointed
I would have loved to see that but Yi
and Alex pier and Sergey pavlovich and
Tom asol is a fantastic freaking Main
Event co-main Event fantastic the the
entire main card is amazing but it's not
gonna bring out the the the casuals it's
just you know they're not gonna order
they're not gonna have a pizza party for
UFC 295 the hardcore is we're going nuts
we love it this card's stacked uh Matt
fola our Boy versus benois St Denise AKA
God of War intense name intense name our
boy Matt is a underdog here um you're
out of your freaking mind if you're
gonna bet against our boy Matt steam
Rolla in his hometown you're out of your
freaking mind dude he's won three in a
row he's coming off that huge wind
knocking uh Drew Dober out he has three
finishes as well he's on a three fight
win streak three finishes I think he
gets it done even though he's a big dog
you're out of your freaking mind you
think I'm B against the steamroller in
New York baby I think he gets it done
and I'm praying he gets it done McKenzie
dur Jessica Andra uh McKenzie dur all
day I think she uh chokes her out just G
draw just kind of she's in a tough path
go go to her uh yeah yeah she she's hit
a tough tough streak here so she's lost
uh she's three uh and six
yeah our last six fight she's won three
she lost a blank field nothing to hang
your head about Yan was a tough one then
Suarez uh you know did work on her as
well she's you know four out of her last
seven she's lost she's a bit of a tough
patch very tough patch um I'm I'm
definitely rolling with McKenzie during
here I think McKenzie gets the the the
sub
here fun fights fun fights and then uh
your co-main event Main Event let's
start with co-main event Sergey
pavlovich Tom Aspen I mentioned you guys
before it's great for the fight fans uh
it's great for the UFC it's great for
the UFC brass it's great for all the
brands involved with the UFC that they
can kind of put together a world title
fight with between Sergey and Tom
aspadol on two weeks donce it's great it
sucks for the fighters cuz and it should
suck for the fans too although they're
you know they're they're filling in and
they have big shoes to to to fill in for
with steep Bay Jon Jones but remember
that you're getting these guys at
80% you know so they they're not going
on full camps um that being said Sergey
pavich and Tom Asen all still ridiculous
fight even on two weeks notice um I
think Tommy gets it done um like you
said last if you watch the show I think
Tom Aspen's fight IQ is much higher this
is not going to be a quick one it's
going to be a a slow burn as the kids
say so I think Tom asmal takes his time
uses his footwork he knows the power of
Sergey early on he also the power of
Serge's hips early on and as that wears
down Tom asinos to start going to work
in the third fourth round I think he
gets a TKO or probably submission in the
late third fourth maybe fifth but I
think third or fourth Tom gets it done
um C sergey's hips are not bad
especially early on he's explosive um
heavy hands Tommy knows this but Tom uh
it's his time man it's his time and then
the main event Yuri and Alex Pier chin
who got on
this have you thought about it yeah I
did so I you I I don't know how to say
this but I I'm going for Yuri I want him
to win I just like him a lot but you
don't like Alex
he's awesome too but I'm just saying
like Yuri's like the more the
personality that I you know I like more
anyway uh watching Yuri's fights he gets
tagged a lot dude right Wild Boy wild
boy yeah but he his Chin's really great
but against Alex dude nuclear Brazilian
bombs it's so accurate too Alex is so
accurate so if I had a pick I think Alex
takes it me too yeah and what what are
the what does DraftKings have as the
odds is Alex a slight favorite or is see
a dog I think he's a slight dog Let me
refresh
this so Alex isus 125 super super slight
favorite plus 105 for Yuri yeah it's
basically even money damn then Tommy
as's minus 118 sergey's minus 102 that's
them going I don't know yeah super close
damn then even uh DN Andra is pretty
close dude they're all so close now for
for MMA these are all like the entire
main card is even basically keep going
all of them are so damn
close that Jared Gordon Mark Matson
that's I'm surprised matson's the the
the dog in that with his wrestling
pedigree that one surprised me if you're
can bet on a dog as much as I love Jared
Gordon if the odds were different I
wouldn't say bet on Madson but he's not
a Bad Bet uh as a slight Underdog
there
all the fights this has to be one of the
closest top to bottom where they're all
pretty even people GNA make mnny baby or
the fights so close they're just gonna
it's you know it's tough to put a parlay
together damn those fights are close uh
yeah I'm with you Yuri does get uh hit a
lot you looking at his his resume click
on him for me you look at his resume
there so he had the win over Glover uh
in the fifth round the Dominic rays
Vulcan CV doway God he's starching dudes
and he's coming off an injury hasn't
fought in a hot second either
um man and it was like one of the worst
shoulder injuries I they say yeah I'm
curious how he comes back after that all
signs would point point towards Alex
Alex wins this he was a champion at
middleweight champion at light
heavyweight he's beat the current
champion at middleweight and Sean
Strickland you want talk dude and he's
had 10 fights I know what in his 10
fights he beat Izzy he beat Sean
Strickland he beat yon bovic and then if
he beats Yi what think how insane that
is UFC Hall Famer probably already but
this would cementum but he has to be the
only guy with 11 fights that gets into
the UFC Hall of Fame first ballot insane
how fast he's got it done and his home
is is at light heavyweight his home's at
light
heavyweight I think people are be
surprised cuz Jan's known as the taller
bigger for a light heavyweight you're
gonna be surprised how big Alex
is people think that's an advantage for
for Yuri you know how big he is and
people G be a little surprised how
massive Alex is and fought at
middleweight yeah I just think Alex his
kicks are going to be a a big issue for
yui
yui he's very Tony Ferg Ferguson is
where it's a Controlled Chaos but when
that chaos meets
technique and and they can find the
openings it gets very difficult for
those guys that thrive in the chaos and
Alex Pier uh is one of those guys at his
level the most elite Striker at light
heavyweight um even Elite Striker at
middleweight any division he's in he's
going to be the best when it comes to
the standup game
and Yuri Yuri can wrestle don't get me
wrong um and I do think he's going to
implement a lot of grappling in this or
try and he's gonna be surprised how good
Alex um defense is remember he's
training with Glover nonstop nonstop so
um I just think it's just a matter of
time before that Brazilian bomb lands on
Yer and I love you I'm with you I love
Yi one of my favorites I just don't like
this as far
as
he just can't take as many risks as he
does that got him you know to be the
champion and not get hit by Alex and
when you get hit by Alex it's game set
match especially at light heavyweight
now but also something be said too here
he hits a lot harder than the guys he's
fighting at
middleweight so we'll see how his chin
holds up as well but I just think Alex
that light heavy and how Wild in the
openings that Y is going to present for
him and also MI in the kicks it it's
going to be a difficult fight for year
yeah and I but also I I don't think it's
one of those quick ones where he like
starches him like you did Sean
Strickland I think he you know yui does
have a chin so he's gonna take a couple
of shots the CR like oh and then he's
gonna grapple I think I think this is a
back and forth um a lot of people are
pting picking Matt uh Steamroller to
have the fight of the night I think it's
going go to your main
event that' be amazing if it does yeah I
think it's going to go down as one of
those great light heavyweight fights of
all time they'll fight again and for
Alex there's so many fun matchups Alex
Canon be a freaking Superstar dude
Superstar Canna be happier for him and
some of note too with you know with
pavlovich everyone's saying you know he
has all these Knockouts and he's starts
everybody in the first round I get all
that but remember this Tom Aspen is one
of Tyson Fury's main training
Partners the best heavyweight on the
planet right now in boxing not named
Francis just kidding uh it's straight
boxing goes the the award still goes to
Tyson Fury but um so you know Tommy
Aspen is used to going with that guy so
I think he can avoid um MMA guy's hands
for 25 minutes and be smart and be coet
and eventually get him down and choke
him out or wear him out enough and use
good footwork where he can capitalize on
his mistakes get him down and uh go to
work on him I just think Tom has too
many ways to win
uh pavlovich has one only one I'll take
the I'll take the Swiss army knife over
the machete all day that Russian machete
I'll take the English Swiss army knife
all day I should just say English knife
but you get the point we get the point
you get it yeah these fights are great
though
fantastic yeah the the one that I'm
circling there it's the it's the last
fight in the early prelims as much as I
love Jared Gordon I know he's been
screwed over so many times since that
Patty fight I'm not crazy about Mark
Matson for him if you know Mark matson's
wrestling back pedigree I I he I know he
lost his last one this dude is a
monster so we'll see what happens yeah
look at look at all those accolades in
wrestling yeah that's insane
nuts what do you got
Jen um first have you ever been to SEMA
chin I've been really yeah I remember I
wasn't I was huge into the the car
culture before yeah how long ago did you
go it was uh I don't know how many it's
it's a long time ago this is when the
import car thing was like big so maybe
like early 2000s around there like when
Fast and Furious came out yeah why she
curies I always want to go if you go it
is incredible oh my God I to go my
friends were there I can't stop it
incred if you're into cars trucks
whatever it is it's like the best of the
best show up there I know yeah it was
just horrible timing for me
yeah horrible timing horrible time we
got a fun project going I'll tell you
when we get off here I don't want yeah
can't wait to hear yeah it's gonna be
[Music]
dope um yeah man any show you see me do
uh your boy is on that happy hippo you
guys know this I've promoted these guys
this one of the few brands that I've
reached out to to personally work with
the show because I believe in their
product is the best creatum on planet
Earth it's the only creatum that I trust
we know that kum's the wild west you
don't know who's sourcing it what you're
putting into your body with happy hippo
you can trust them they have all then
they have so many versions they got the
powders right here that is the I think
that's the mango grapefruit flavor which
I love they have the taffies the gummies
uh the highly concentrated shots the
energy shots which I love they have it
all you go to happy hippo.com promod is
thick with three C's 23 you get 20% off
for life so go get you some right
now
alrighty so one of the biggest things
that came out in the last few days is uh
this report but by the way so this
report is apparently from Dave Meltzer
who's very trustworthy with the from the
wrestling Observer as far as
pay-per-view numbers I haven't seen
anything that he posted publicly but
apparently he talked about it on one of
his radio shows and then these uh
websites are you know grabbing that
content from that so he's saying
apparently I'll show you this right here
so this is a quote from him he goes uh
this was regarding the Francis Fury
fight he goes I will have the exact
numbers tomorrow but they were
terrible um way below an aew all elite
wrestling pay-per-view possibly 10K for
TV orders I'm not buying this I will
have the streaming tomorrow it was
nothing close to Canelo vers Nate or
Jake uh vers Nate and then I saw this
well not Canelo versus Nate but canelo's
pay-per-view against
Charlo um per Dave melzer Francis Ty
pery only did uh 11,500 TV pay-per-view
Buys in the US and 56,000 on streams on
espm plus but these are all from proxies
they're not from I I don't you have to
subscribe to Dave meltzer's substack or
whatever to find out so I don't know
exactly but this is what's in the you
know there's headlines in the Daily Mail
MMA Mania and these other here's where
it gets dicey and Cha's allude to this
so many times remember how they said uh
Conor was Floyd biggest pay-per-view of
all time there's no way to prove it the
only the the the people that are
promoting the event or that involved in
it know the actual numbers so it's kind
of like Netflix or Howard Stern on
serus so on Netflix they say these crazy
numbers this is the most streamed
special in the world this most watch
show over you know a hundred billion
people watch the Jeffrey dmer uh TV show
and you're like okay there's no way to
confirm this there's absolutely no way
to confirm this but what the numbers
that we do have to confirm it all signs
would point that
this fight with Francis and Tyson was
lower than
expected but let's talk about the
expectations here
because if you go back Francis and Gano
was NE you go you look at his
pay-per-view numbers bring it up look at
his pay-per-view numbers on the UFC chin
he was never known as a big payper
review star never that was not his Mo
and that's one of the reasons Dana White
let him
walked he was never a huge huge
pay-per-view star he he he's
just you know no just bring bring in
francano uh UFC pay-per-view numbers if
you type in pay-per-view numbers it's
just gonna be Fury right
gotta I think since that's the biggest
thing right now what uh France Franc and
ganu
I think since it's a big headline now
that's why it's tough to find but oh
it's
annoying is that up there is that it
right there go up uh paper typology we
give it a
shot that's like the most ever he's not
going to be in that category but even
though we don't have the exact numbers
it would been nice to have them but even
though we don't have them the the point
is is is there shouldn't be that
shocking just because Francis has never
been a major pay-per-view star amongst
his own peers amongst his own fan base
he was never a massive pay-per-view draw
he just wasn't Tyson Fury if you go over
his boxing numbers Tyson Fury's
pay-per-view box numbers he also isn't
the biggest especially in America
so yeah all it is it's gonna be because
that's the number one topic right now
that's so stupid but um so you have two
guys who aren't not known for being
these massive stars you know in
pay-per-view it's just not um one of the
reasons we can believe that Floyd
Mayweather and Conor's numbers were high
are they as high as everyone saying
probably not but uh the reason we can
assume that did pretty damn well is
Conor McGregor's the biggest
pay-per-view star of all time so he's a
proven commodity in the UFC his fan base
then Floyd May weather the biggest
boxing pay-per-view star of all time
proven commodity you put those together
even if half the boxing fan base hates
it half the MMA fan base hates boxing
you still put it together you got a
pretty big ass pay-per-view Francis fan
base has never really rode with him and
bought him as a pay-per-view star Tyson
Fury even though he's massive has never
was never the biggest pay-per-view star
so if you put them together you would
assume it's not going to go crazy
good so we all talked about Deontay
Wilder Tyson Fury remember how big of a
fight that was remember how insane that
was 3 125,000 pay-per-view byes yeah my
point is neither guy from his respective
Fields whether it's box or MMA even
though they're the best of the best we
just because they're the best doesn't
mean they're pay-per-view Stars so he
put them together even though it's this
weird dynamic of the greatest
heavyweight at fighting and our current
UFC champion heavyweight fighting
you put them together that doesn't mean
it's going to be a huge pay-per-view
success there's so much that goes into
pay-per-view it takes a while for
someone become a pay-per-view star it's
just what it is so when I heard it's low
I that makes sense weird time of
day start at 11 didn't end to five weird
production it's in Saudi
Arabia Francis you know he left the UFC
this fight took a while to come to
fruition um a lot of lot of the box
fan base wanted Fury to fight usyk right
away didn't happen they thought this was
a gimmick then there's always that
constant kind of hate that these kind of
quote unquote circus fights get where
the general consumer the casuals go oh
it's all fake that narrative remember
how long it's taking Jake Paul to get
out of that narrative even Logan Paul
has to deal with that Francis Tyson have
to deal even walk in here some Is that
real no way Tyson would be even come
close to losing that guy I'm like oh no
so once that Nar is pushed so much
people they don't you know a lot of
people are sheep they don't think for
themselves they're like oh it's F that
stuff's fake okay so they have to deal
with that narrative so then people
aren't buying into that so they they're
dealing with a lot of trash they're
dealing with a lot of fake news and so I
think that hurts the pay-per-view sales
um again and the pure box imp purist
don't want to see this and then Francis
not being a big Cash Cow for the UFC it
makes sense do I think it was this low
no no I don't think we'll ever know um I
also don't think Saudi Arabia cares no
they have so much money I think they're
just doing it to entertain themselves
you know the Chic or the king or what
you call them the guy who everyone loves
or they have to you know or they
disappear um I think they have to uh you
know they're doing it for the to get
their own rocks off it's it's a way to
flex on the world so mission
accomplished there they this is also
been done too with Saudi Arabia they get
these massive you know Premier League
guys to come over and play soccer there
you look at the stadiums there's like
150 people in the stands and they've
paid damn near billion dollars to get
these guys over there so not a lot of
people tuning into that either so I
don't think they care um here's where it
hurts uh Francis and Tyson this is what
bums me out about it you know The
Narrative of it being fake is whatever
you got to be a [__] to think that but
the The Narrative that Low's paper of
all time that's probably not true it's
probably somewhere in the middle um so
all
good the issue with all of this
is last week how high were we on Francis
and got him still super high on what
he's achieved is one of the greatest
accomplishments in Combat Sports the
issue when it comes down to the business
side is if Anthony Joshua sees those
numbers if Deontay Wilder sees those
numbers and now you know it's a tougher
fight than you thought it was going to
be who's gonna fight Francis now when
those numbers were so low against Tyson
Fury who is a bigger star than Deontay
Wilder who is arguably a bigger star
than Anthony Joshua he has his Show on
Netflix Americans are more familiar with
him now is he a bigger star in the UK I
don't know that's up for debate all I'm
saying is these guys that view Tyson or
I'm sorry used Francis as his cash cow
and and thought it was an easy fight now
they realize it's not an easy fight not
only is it not an easy fight it's not an
easy payday a lot of people aren't
paying attention to
it now the risk isn't worth the reward
so who does
that kind of um who does that affect
most Francis so now Deontay Wilder is
going yesh man I thought this was gonna
be a big deal it's not I'm G stick to
boxing Anthony Joshua last week Eddie
Hearn Anthony Joshua's Handler was
saying Joshua we would definitely
consider this and then it then the
pay-per-view numbers come out and they
go Anthony Joshua wants to be the world
champion he justes want to do these
circus acts so no notice they're all up
on my boys Francis nuts last week now
the numbers come out everyone's going
uhuh because a it's not gonna be this
massive fight you think it was going to
be and B it ain't gonna be a walk in the
park you need to beat up you might beat
him but you're going to have a tough
fight in your hands who's signing up for
that now you got to Hope if you're a
Fran fan if you're a nicksick fan who's
the greatest coach we have in the game
right now if you're a fan of those boys
you got to Hope Deontay Wilder anony
Joshua and you got to hope the Saudis
especially the Saudis offer an insane
amount of
money because even if you're Francis
yeah this is a black guy in your career
a little bit but if you beat usk do you
really want to go back and fight this
Francis guy again when you know people
didn't tune in like you thought they
were we just got to Hope saudi's like we
don't care I'm doing to impress this
chick
that's what we got hope for I don't care
trying to smash this girl over here
dude that's why we got hope for because
because now all the money's not there
all the hype's not
there but the Saudis know the real
pay-per-view numbers you know no one
knows so no one knows but it but the the
I guarantee it didn't go great but it
didn't go as bad as everyone I know the
reported stuff is
like but again this is what this is a
soci we live in now where any narrative
even though you don't have to have any
proof people will run with it like crazy
you know and then it get said enough
times and people just assume it's facts
Jake Jake Paul you know those fights are
fixed Tyson Fury Francis the fight was
so close it's fixed and people buy into
that instead of looking to it themselves
or watching themselves they see a clip
on Instagram like oh my God that was
fixed you know think me Jake Paul Clips
came out on Instagram when he knocked
out Woodley oh look at it here Woodley
looks like he takes a slip here and then
nobody most people didn't buy the fight
so they see that like oh yeah those are
fixed when it can be further from the
truth that's the world we live in man
yeah so um the bummer is Tyson's gonna
Tyson he goes on to fight usyk in a in a
a legit world championship fight for
Francis that's who I'm worried about
because if the numbers are are that low
and they and I'm sure the managers can
get the actual numbers you're not going
to track those big big names like Wilder
and Joshua now or even Tyson the rematch
that's what you got to worry
about and Francis does supposedly in his
contract has a fight for the pfl in
March not a lot going on there if that
was a tough fighter for we were to lose
all this goes away so it's not worth it
so I'm I'm sure they're feeling offers
now I feel like Wilder would be down to
do it
still yeah I've had to bet my money
would go towards Wilder in a boxing
match
that's what I think happens next for him
and I hope so what else you got Jen that
would be a great fight though hell yeah
two crazy ass Sluggers uh okay so I
thought this was kind of funny so Dana
White was on Donald Trump Jr's pod or
yeah I think it's his podcast a video
podcast and then he said he didn't watch
The Francis Zano Tyson Fury fight oh
he's lying I know right immediately I
thought come on he's full of [__] but he
did say like here's this quote right
here
so this is him talking to Trump Jr he
says the fact that he went 10 Rounds
with Tyson Fury is crazy he just went 10
Rounds with Tyson Fury con Conor
McGregor made it nine or 10 with Floyd
Anthony P just beat Roy Jones I know Roy
is freaking 60 years old or whatever but
I don't know what the hell is going on
it's crazy I didn't see the fight but
the fact they went 10 rounds is
unbelievable he hilarious at least he
gave him some Kudos yeah he did I didn't
see it but I heard it went well you saw
it dude of course dude that's like when
you break up with your hot X and she she
meets like her husband has like kids
like yeah good for her I don't see it
but I
heard
okay any yeah that's that was just
interesting because he definitely saw
the fight everyone saw the fight yeah of
course he watched it um and this sucks
we reported last week I guess uh Tyson's
trainer said he would probably be in the
top 10 because he you know well most of
us think that Tyson oh sorry most of us
think that Francis won that fight the
boxing match but he's ranked officially
at 500 90 what out of 1 no no we weren't
going based off just like go since he
went to you know close Tois with with
Fury he's going to be in the top 10 no
no somebody in boxing leaked that that
was the report last week remember it was
like w w WBO is going to rank Tyson in
the top 10 WC gonna rank France in the
top 10 that's where the MMA side got it
we don't know the how the rankings work
we're not in your world you guys told us
this and they him at 59
how dare you 59 after he basically
almost beat Tyson Fury which we you know
the majority of us think we did or he
did yeah you know is is France a top 10
box it it'd be tough to put him as top
10 it'd be tough to put at top 20 I know
because it's first yeah but again I
wasn't even assuming
that I I I'm not the one that we're not
the ones in here that start this roomies
me ranked the top 10 WBO leaked that so
we're like oh that's we're cheering our
boy on and they're like psych 590 590
there even 590 heavyweights in the
world not good
ones it it so someone commented there
goes I hate boxing that's not Terence
Crawford is it no that's Terence our boy
basketball
player oh word Terence Ross I thought it
Terence Crawford like yeah that's
aggressive shout out to Terrence yeah
Terren is the best but yeah I I forgot
who was I think his trainer but then we
saw an article about like the W no no we
did his trainer didn't say that [__] we
no it came from boxing MMA is not going
to say the WBO wcoo whatever the hell
their leagues are their you know all
their [__] is going to rank France
top 10 nobody in MMA reported that that
came from the boxing side and then
someone was like hold up no no
590 don't even rank him dude F
off we reported last week it was
somewhere on in that again it could be
fake news and we
got see it was Ring magazine
okay they were the
ones wait see and everyone's slamming it
that that's not right right he shouldn't
be in top 10 so they they SED him okay
either either way hold on to be right
yeah don't put that on us Chen I know I
just want to make sure it's correct
though is going to to be ranked by the
WBC here's what we
means there so so hold on according to
one of his head coaches Dewey
Cooper who's a boxing coach again not a
m coach he's a boxing coach going to be
ranked in the top 10 of the division
after this fight with Fury so his coach
did say that and then so Marcio the
president of the W WBC said he's going
to be rank him in the there you go the
pre ready see I'm tell MMA we
we I'm telling you dude it didn't come
from our side we they' be insane if MMA
was like he's top 10 we don't know we
don't control the rankings that's like
saying we would put F Tyson Fury top 10
heavyweight right you're not that that's
not how it works so we don't know how it
works so the president of the WBC said
he's going to rank him in the top 10
because he's better than most of the
heavyweights in the top 10 he said that
in the ring he said that in the ring so
absolutely you'll see him again hold on
this is so just to be completely correct
um Mauricio suam man whatever president
WC WBC said he's going to rank him in
the top 10 because he's better than most
heavyweights in the top 10 said cooper
cooper is the coach so Cooper's the
boxing coach who spoke to the president
of the WBC after the fight in the ring
again it came from the president of the
WBC we didn't ask for this we didn't ask
for it no and then you rank him 59 like
dumb asses all right you're the one that
would say you're rank the top 10 we
never said
that I don't trust that guy look at him
I don't trust that
guy anyways he's 590 right now
apparently you how you yeah okay don't
rank him though just some do his
thing okay uh I don't know if you had a
chance to see this it's such a long clip
but it's pretty crazy so it's basically
aiel helwani and chel sunnon arguing
about uh Francis nanu versus Tyson Fury
and the majority over like who won or I
haven't seen this by the way the
majority of the argument was about the
pay like Ariel I guess Ariel said that
he would get 10 to 20 million for the
fight and then CH was like you realize
10 to 20 million that's 100% difference
right that's a huge difference
then what if you got 10 million versus
20 million that's 100% difference well
it's based on pay-per-view sales yeah
but I'm saying like that's a huge you
know that's a huge like jump right so
it's 10 million yeah that's a huge
that's that's 100% it's all predicated
but they but we knew he was going to get
10 million and then if the pay-per-view
went well he has the the potential to
get 20 million is that what Ariel saying
here no so
sh it was kind of like back and for it
was so confusing either way though the
main thing that happened was the discrep
Rey of pay and then cha got super upset
with Ariel and Ariel started like I
can't play this clip but it was like
play for me I haven't seen this no we
we're live though we can't do it oh damn
play it for me after here's the thing
though but I haven't seen any of it hand
to God this isn't like a Dana White real
quick before you answer so CH was like I
could he got pissed off I could strangle
you you and then Arrow's like be you
know something like uh he was calling
out CH like say it's in my face you're
being a [__] or something a coward
[__] very contentious I watch the
entire thing so yeah so you okay you you
know more than I do probably I mean yeah
there let me ask you this case Okay do
we think it's
real so I did and then I was talking to
my brother about it and he was like
they're both from the school of like WWE
remember they're both WWE fans they both
know that this gets ratings they both
know that this is GNA make all the
airwaves if it was fake there and
remember they you both they're very
close they both had a show together
clearly they both had a show together
they show together on
ESPN yeah yeah you're definitely Chang
my mind so as soon as someone told me
that they had an issue I'm like oh it's
a it's a gig like it's it's a bit but
you should watch it because if it is
fake they're both tremendous actors like
it felt real let's say they it's they
started off as a thing it seemed like it
got real like it seemed like it actually
got real to the point where chill like
hung up on him he was like I got this is
a like [__] move but I got to go like
it was and it was like 40 50 minutes it
was a long and CH does that kind of you
know like silly thing where he slams the
computer and gets out but this time it
was it was a little bit but was like
encouraged him to like fight him what's
up ER was like bring it on he's like say
to my say it to my face if I know what
you're talking about blah dude he was
calling them names that dude literally
if you said that to anyone in real life
they're going to fight you you know he
would never say that to him in real life
no of course not or or they're such good
friends like C obviously this is
like like Brian versus AR will be a good
fight right like neither one can
fight me and Cha right we both have
background in professional fighting so
clearly Chael knows that so you're gonna
give Ariel a Long Leash as far as what
he can say before you physically touch
him Brian can get away he can call me
whatever the worst things you've ever
heard of clearly we have a deep
relationship like CH and Ariel I've
never beat up Bri like Brian could do
whatever he wants yeah and CH didn't say
he's gonna so ch's not gonna like you
can't threaten a journalist he didn't
say can't threaten a journalist I can't
threaten Brian at 60 yeah like that
doesn't farewell for
anybody you should definitely watch this
clip afterwards because I do feel like
there are undertones where they they do
kind of like there's issues with them
you can tell like there's like well
clear there's a past right so like with
me and Brian Brian can say things that
you guys wouldn't know about that would
definitely strike your nerve like oh
hell no exactly clearly there's no rep
clearly there's no physical
repercussions that's how it felt that's
how it felt yeah I bet I bet it's like
it's like a married couple fighting that
stuff happens and it's good for TV a
married couple fighting in front of
their friends that's what that sounds
like yeah yeah we at dinner like oh okay
prob I'm gonna get out of here I'm I'm
good I don't want dessert I'm just gonna
get home this is awkward I bet they'll
be fine I bet they talked
after yeah I imagine they would I mean
they kept saying like I mean Chay even
said like we're friends we're friends
but then it just got deeper and deeper
maybe there's some you know some uh some
other drama we don't know about yeah
again it's all the Real Housewives of
the UFC that's all this is this is the
newest scuffle like somebody on Bravo TV
show you know and then we all talk about
it that's how it goes I bet they're fine
they they've know each other forever
yeah of
course okay so this is another one ER
since we're talking about Errol helani
so he uh posted this on November 4th
saying that it's not finalized yet but
makach versus Charles Olivera 2 was
goingon to headline UFC 297 that's what
he
thought and then right after
that uh Ali abdell aiz said no that's
not
happening and it gets a little crazier
here why does everyone come from an
Ariel right now I guess cuz he put it
out there I don't I don't know dude yeah
but but Ariel's legit journalist like
and so he get has he has to like fact
check all his stuff so Ariel's not a guy
like you know some of these other weird
MMA sites that leak stuff and to get
clicks and cuz Ariel knows if he does
that he'll lose all credibility and
that's why if you hear if I hear from
Brad akamoto if I hear from Luke Thomas
or Ariel it's facts it's facts because
they have that track record because
they're legit journalist the rest of the
stuff out there don't it's just all to
get clicks and Views and create you know
a narrative it's all crap but if you
hear it from Ariel especially Luke
Thomas or Brett it's going down dude if
you hear from me probably not going down
I don't fact check or have sources I I
may have some good sources but if they
even get a sniff of it and they tell me
like all right I'm running with it cuz I
don't
care these guys their their entire
careers are being journalists like legit
journalist dude so for Ali to be like
guys don't don't listen obviously they
don't like each other guys please don't
listen to people who can't even get
credential in the UFC fake news bat yeah
again but you got to remember Ariel's
just not being like Oh what will get me
clicks oh here's a main event coming up
you know why is everyone going for Ariel
I don't Ariel I got your back DG I got
your back uh and then hold on this is
how erel responded I double checked and
this is this is crazy Ariel got pretty
good Ariel got pretty good here's little
sniper
so he put uh don't believe you know fake
news [__] and then erel goes uh or and
then he goes don't believe anybody who
can't even get a UFC credential there
but hey at least you can get on a plane
and leave the country yeah that goes
deep oh do they keep going no no I'm
saying that goes deep though yeah yeah
that's a deep cut there uh but yeah
since then uh Brett okamoto pointed out
that yeah they makev and Charles O will
not headline UFC 297 and I heard from
around this area our friends maybe like
as soon as arol announced it the the UFC
team got pissed off and like [__] we're
going to change it now or something I
don't know if that's UFC wouldn't do
that Ariel don't have that much of a
influence on the UFC we're like oh Ariel
announced the before us we're changing
the entire
card we can't let him announce it no
they wouldn't do that whoever told you
that uh sipping that drama juice yeah
someone outside there yeah yeah yeah
don't listen to whoever told you that
and let me know who it is is cuz I'll
fire them um so the bathroom it is
interesting
that I'm sure Ariel's going to say it on
his show he's probably doing it live as
we do do ours live who gave him that
info because again Ariel's track record
is the most legit journalist we have
close thing we have to you know a legit
journalist in this weird MMA game and
for him to say Mev trou deliver at twos
happened in Toronto said which is he's
Canadian yeah but so he got some word on
again Ariel's not just gonna it's not
like some guy at Starbucks like hey I
heard I I have a friend who works at the
UFC and AR was like oh really and then
tweet that out he had a legit source
multiple sources he always multi
multiple sources that probably work
within the UFC that they were headed in
that direction and so he felt good
enough to tweet that out um but sounds
like it's definitely not
happening because that Brad okamoto who
works for the UFC and ESPN but Islam and
Charles to well not headline UFC 297 per
Dana White per Dana
White as of now Olivera does appear to
be the most likely 155 Challenger
although Dana White says anything is
possible so who knows yeah and that card
was supposed to be it sounds like just
maybe his s it looked like they had that
direction for whatever reason they went
another Direction and then Ali and all
these guys jump on him but anyone who
thinks that the UFC would change a
pay-per-view because Ariel leaked it
before you stupid
think think how much that goes into a
pay-per-view Main Event like aiel leaked
it change everything all the flights
let's cost us millions of dollars the
marketing never just the headliners n
that's stupid yeah so anyways head the
card the original Headliners were
supposed to be vul and Toria but
honestly vul is you know that's
interesting everyone going out aiel for
now
huh I don't know um so I just saw this
can we all just get along I saw this pop
up too um apparently Netflix is
entertaining the boxing business wow
right and then I guess Jak according to
the Wall Street Journal uh Jake Paul
might be affiliated with it and then
they're looking into possibly streaming
premere boxing champions though they
need a home and sports is the most
watched
like sports is the most watched like
Live Events Netflix you know MH and then
also with writer strikes I'm sure
they're back on content as far as
scripted uh Series so yeah life Sports
is is is the future so I could
definitely see Netflix jumping in that
bed interesting yeah so that mean
they're going to charge extra money if
it's live if we're already paying for
the subscription I wonder if it's it's G
be like ESPN ESPN plus that's true cuz I
pay for ESPN I pay for ESPN plus and I
got to pay for the pay-per-view which is
like you [__] getting three different
payments in one month [__]
what yeah and you have to have the
subscription to even buy the
pay-per-view which sucks but anyway and
do we have any news on Jake Jake Paul's
next opponent he just says a boxer with
a winning winning
record I don't know I can Google it
right now though it would be yeah it'd
be news if I'm sure it' be all over but
from what I heard it's just a boxer with
a wi winning
record
all right we'll look at look for it
afterwards that's all right uh so a few
bout announcements [__] it you w to do
it right now we'll do n [__] it now
let's talk about Armen versus freaking
uh Dar no it's a great fight 50 people
are gonna watch great
fight it's a phenomenal fight hear I
hear I'm I'm one of the 50 hardcores
here
man oh my God okay you're the guy that
thinks UFC cancels Main Events if cuz
Ariel man that's came from we talk to
some people we talk to some people uh
all right so this is there's a Fight
Night headliner for December 2 amazing
fight I I was just being silly here
amazing such a good fight it is it is
and also o
same uh Bobby green Dan hooker they've
been talking about doing this fight but
uh yeah apparently it's that's a great
fight happening there and then your
favorite I know you're looking forward
to this
one uh roal Pennington versus Myro Bueno
Silva for the the vacant bantamweight
title speaking of 50 people
watching yeah yeah it is what it is man
yeah hell yeah uh I thought this was
super funny I don't okay so Mark
Zuckerberg he had an MCL injury right
and he posted about it or sorry ACL
injury uh sparring and he said he was
supposed to have a MMA fight early next
was it yeah early next year but it's got
to be postponed but the way this post
looks is just like someone in like the
UFC or MMA you know what I mean of
course no he his marking team his PR
team was like dude people think you're
such a cuck we got to do something here
are you into anything he's like ah I
don't know the Teslas no I don't like
them because of Elon they're like all
right we come with some narrative to at
least win you over some dude fans man
you like Jiu-Jitsu he's like I guess
like cool we're gonna run with this
Jiu-Jitsu thing so he starts doing
Jiu-Jitsu then they start leaking the
fight he starts you know hanging out
with and one Championship Fighters and
then now here we are he's he's in the r
and he blew his uh back out or whatever
I love look he's all it's just like one
of those posts that any UFC fighter do
oh no it's the same post gusin posted
after he went to the greatest war of all
time with Jon Jones for the light
heavyweight title it's almost look at
him I know he's GNA be all right guys
God willing I love look at hey UFC
fighters you guys know that's all the
John John we got this brother Izzy love
you dude he's a get better bro hner my
boy dang sorry to hear Mark nah I love
nah sorry to hear Mark wish you the
speedy recovery John my
man everyone just like oh get you're a
warrior dude get better
bro oh man that's such a shame I was
looking forward to your fight
bro
oh look at all these guys you know what
I don't want you know what I don't want
I don't want your shitty freaking
metaverse glass classes so I'm not going
to suck you off here Mark oh did you did
you break a nail training dude and now
you're in the ER taking pictures like
your gusin that you went five rounds
with the greatest fighter of all time
he's all hopefully one day dude gonna
delay the fight for now everyone's like
oh man I was stoked on that bro oh dude
I was dying to see you perform man
you've been looking great lately oh man
just when your striking was coming
together oh dude dude sucks man you just
fig out the [__] UMO PL oh plumber
bro we're have to wait for your
debut oh thanks for the meta glasses bro
like even our boy uh Mikey musham Mesi
was like oh damn dude thanks for the new
metaverse Ray bang glasses get better
soon brother see you next week
man yeah I want nothing from this
freaking robot your fighting sucks your
Jitsu sucks your platform sucks you suck
how about that damn dud Instagram just
got deleted I know oh no dude I forgot
about that they control my
life I think okay oh dude
such oh man are you kidding me just when
2023 couldn't get any worse now we're
can see Zuckerberg fight get better
bro it
was
hilarious
oh oh man first they robbed France say
now you're taking zucker's fight away
from us oh 2024 can't come soon
enough what hey what exactly happened to
him his entire left leg's in a freaking
cast his hands
broke this ACL like what the Tor my ACL
sparring just got a surgery to replace
it uh part of the game so many fight
miles this stuff happens am I right
Jones grateful for the doctor's team
taking care of me I was training for my
very competitive MMA fight early next
year but now that's delayed uh the worst
still looking forward to doing it after
I recover good luck to my opponent
thanks everyone for the love and support
fight on you added a couple words there
but
yeah um oh
no so oh I just got my new 10 oz winning
gloves oh
that's why I have two legs I'll work on
my right kick that is aggressive for an
AC injury right that look that looks
crazy uh anyway do you want to get into
this blew my left leg out kicking
somebody's ass part of the
game you're crazy if you don't think I'm
putting that OCTA on my backyard still
right wifey post our
text what else you got post our textt
what you did yeah she did yeah um do you
know much about the whole Anti-Trust
lawsuit and they're like they're showing
like how much money UFC fighters made
undisclosed yeah I don't it's kind of
like to me it's a little bit boring but
super deep cut you can the the oh no no
the the information that they released
um I got a where do I want to go on this
I know some stuff you guys don't know
um I'll play friendly for now because I
know the some numbers that they're not
showing on here but
um overall it's such a bad look for the
UFC because if you look how many
pay-per-views Conor sold and how much
he's actually paid according to these
reports it's a fraction so you can when
you guys hate on these you know the
Francis leaving the UFC fighting Fury
when you hate on guys uh leaving the
Woodley and Ben Asen leaving the UFC
fighting Jake Paul this should show you
a little bit of insight of why they do
it they are not set they are not
billionaires they are not millionaires
by any means think how massive Conor
McGregor is think how famous Conor
McGregor is then look at the amount of
money Accord of these reports that he
was paid think of Ronda Rousey how
massive she is think of how many
pay-per-views she sold how many
pay-per-views Conor McGregor sold think
of Jon Jones the greatest of all time
when you look at the numbers that are
released you're like oh that's not what
I thought it was that's why so many
people are upset at the UFC and how much
of a monopoly they have and how much
power they have over the fighters this
it's going to get worse for the
UFC there's stuff that I I'm not gonna
again I shoot from the hip and the
sources I know what my eyes have seen
and I know how much certain people were
paid and I know the numbers that they're
showing on there and this is where it
gets
tricky because then you're talking about
a different set of problems with the UFC
cuz the numbers that they're reporting I
saw
different I'll say that all right so but
this is what they have to report to the
IRS so I I don't know I don't know all I
know is no matter what the numbers are
this is going to highlight and this is
such a deep cut that most of the
Public's not even going to care because
you got to really go down the the rabbit
hole here but just know that even con
McGregor according to
these numbers wasn't compensated like he
should be or how you think he was I'll
say that okay fair enough uh one more
and then uh case oh
no I'll need Casey's help on this one so
uh this is a post by Fabo verdom and by
the way Terence mckeny reposted this and
so it says right here I don't know how
to say this I don't want to say it right
here that's his post right the com happy
anniversary yeah Feliz
anio I don't want to say that I know so
that's what I'm saying let's not but
then but that's his daughter it must be
right I don't know for a fact that mean
happy birthday so I'm going to do the
see the C translation I'm going to click
that okay it's off okay what's off no I
just took he's taking off screen because
I'm just showing you this now oh cool so
look at this I don't know how this
happens Terence mckin posted
this dude that's not real this is
Instagram so I'm
like how's that
possible so anyone cancelled now because
Instagram screwed him on the translation
he's like no I didn't no I didn't mean
that man no no
no it's so crazy his daughter's probably
like oh my God I have so many comments
on that birthday post Dad thank you so
much
uh I don't know what to say I I don't
know to say that can't be that can't be
real dude so if anyone wants to see it
go to FBO verdun's Instagram post about
a happy birthday and then and then go to
C translation and it's just crazy dude
that it's so
crazy I stay away from that one man I
know just showing you but may I don't
know maybe this is naked
I don't know if that's the nickname
that's so I don't know I Don't Speak
Portugese I don't know but I assume that
word in any language is frown
upon oh man these are some fun cament oh
man first Zuckerberg gets freaking hurt
and now ver Doom call
his it's just now ver Doom called his
daughter to the Ed word oh 2024 get here
now
I don't know how that translation
happened but I don't either someone
Instagram's getting
fired oh man well you see
295 so funny oh man PO for do he's all
wait but also fix it foro fix it ASAP
even if the translation's off just get
rid of that word
man oh man I tell you what a bu I'm
excited for Yuri Alex uh Sergey Tom asan
all that's going down UFC 295 is this
freaking Saturday so get yourself some
cold ones and enjoy this amazing UFC 295
card shout out to our boy Matt steam
Rolla for Rolla get it done against the
God of War my man we're rooting for you
here a thick boy uh my my eyes on that
Jered Gordon Mark Matson fight I'm
excited for that one but uh you guys
know my picks Tommy Aspen Alex Pier Matt
steam Rolla and uh yeah can't wait this
a great card enjoy it Fellers and ladies
shout out to
verom I'll I'll be on door my next door
dates uh until Zuckerberg sees this and
kills me uh December 8th and 9th Friday
Saturday only two shows one two shows
Friday 7 and N uh two shows Saturday 7
and N that's in downtown Chicago come
get some chai toown I'll be trying your
deep dish pizza AKA casseroles uh then
Nashville January 25th and uh it's one
night only in Nashville January 25th
that's a Thursday then January 26 27th
that Friday Saturday I jump on over to
Austin so get your tickets we got
Edmonton San Jose Vancouver's on there
Fort Worth Plano Texas we're all over uh
get your tickets thick boy.com is that
it that's it oh man Mark Zuckerberg all
right love you guys I'm out be nice to
each
other